Congratulations on completing
your LinkedIn profile.
As you continue your job hunt,
remember your three Rs,
reflect, research, and relate.
Revisit this exercise, and make sure
your professional materials line up to
these areas themes and keywords.
Remember the three goals you want to
achieve with your LinkedIn profile.
Goal 1, use keywords to
show up in search results.
Goal 2,
make sure your profile stands out.
Goal 3, signal that you are qualified
and motivated for your desired job.
Finally, remember that LinkedIn is
a powerful tool that can lead to great
opportunities not a hurdle.
For additional resources, check out
the links and instructor notes.